[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight sophie louie good
evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the race to contain highly
contagious
new variants while ruling out vaccines
to protect us from covet 19.
in canada that rollout is not going as
first planned
in the last two weeks vaccine supplies
have slowed to a trickle
while variants keep spreading new
variants have now been detected in
six provinces at least 195 cases have
been confirmed
the full extent of the spread is not
certain because canada's capacity to
screen for variants
is limited the clock is ticking and
these highly transmissible
new variants will not wait for more
tests or for public health officials and
political leaders to decide
how to try to contain them if those
variants become
achieve dominance viral dominance in
alberta all of our current public health
measures
would be totally inadequate to contain
it
and all of the sacrifices that we have
made
as a society and every albertan
individually
would be overwhelmed yet
alberta and some other provinces are
preparing to lift some public health
restrictions
at the same time the government is
struggling to get vaccine doses into the
country
and into the arms of canadians here's
how canada compares to other g7
countries with mass vaccination programs
according to our world in data project
as of monday canada had administered
just over 2.5 doses per 100 people
the uk had administered nearly 15 doses
per 100 people
the government says canada is still on
track to get
6 million doses of the moderna and
pfizer biontech vaccines
by the end of march canada is also
expecting more than a million doses of
the astrazeneca vaccine which
is not yet approved for use the supply
is coming through the kovacs program
which was set up primarily to help
low-income countries access
vaccines canada is one of the few
wealthy countries which contributed to
the program
and is now opted to dip into the supply
in the first round
of distribution that will not help
canada
right now and as heather urex west
reports
there is evidence the variants are
already spreading through the community
and the window to try to contain them
has already closed
it was a concerning development in
alberta that prompted an immediate
change of policy
despite all efforts to contain it
students at two calgary schools and an
alberta day care
have now been exposed to the more
transmissible variant first detected in
the uk
after returning travelers past the virus
to their kids
one of the themes we are seeing in
alberta and one that has been reported
in other places
is that it can be more difficult to
effectively quarantine or isolate away
from other household members
with variant strains of covid returning
travelers are now being asked to
quarantine at a hotel
if they do not all household contacts
must quarantine
for 24 days even if we cannot contain it
100 percent
it we need to slow it because there is
so much about these new variants that we
still
don't know like if current covet 19
safety protocols in schools
will be enough to prevent viral spread
though now that there's been exposures
we'll soon find out with this more or
less this amount of
uh of the new of uk variant that we
already have in community
it will um it will become dominant
around march 7th this university of
calgary researchers says mathematical
models suggest
in alberta containment is just too late
but alberta and other provinces are
moving forward with reopening plans
anyways
though alberta's premier admits that
businesses opening next week
could have to close again i know no one
wants to be on the roller coaster but we
cannot guarantee people
that there won't be a change of policy
in the future
because as cases of the new variant
spread much of what we've come to know
about living with coven 19
may need to change heather urex west
global news
calgary testing as always
is key to tracking the spread of the
virus these new
variants require another level of
testing beyond the basic
covid test it's called genomic
sequencing
and it's being ramped up across the
country eric sorenson explains
how and why we've counted on a simple
formula to get us beyond covet 19 a lock
down to hold it down
then vaccinate to eradicate the new
covet variants have shaken up that
outlook
we're in a very delicate period right
now this virus evolves
and changes over time even with small
numbers so far the mutations are so much
more transmissible that provinces are
making changes
we have stepped up our surveillance we
are monitoring and testing
british columbia has begun random
sampling in targeted areas such as this
school in maple ridge and at st
paul's hospital in vancouver after cases
of variants were found
bc and others like alberta and ontario
are testing a percentage of positive
covet 19 results
looking for mutations and they are
genomic sequencing some to identify
specific variants
quebec has announced an 11 million
dollar investment to sequence 65 000
positive samples
for emerging variants by year-end it's
clearly
the right path to proceed with caution
with these variants
and even though we see case numbers
dropping
in much of canada it's going to be
harder and harder
to keep that same trajectory if that
variant is spreading
indeed covet 19 numbers are coming down
provinces are looking to reopen schools
in the economy
but the variants inject new uncertainty
as schools open
we want to know are schools going to be
accelerating the pandemic in particular
are they going to be accelerating the
penetration of the new variants
we only know that if we do surveillance
and surveillance includes
testing the variants have accelerated
the urgency for vaccinations
covet 19 has spread in the population
from one person to the next and then on
to many more from all the infections
eventually came
mutations vaccines can protect the
remaining population from the original
covet 19 virus
they may also limit the impact of the
variants plus
mass vaccination removes an enormous
pool of potential infections
from which more mutations could develop
viruses
cannot mutate if they don't replicate
and if you stop their replication by
vaccinating
widely you will not get mutations but
with vaccine deliveries to canada
stalled by the manufacturers and the
growth of variants still an unknown
there are no easy decisions for
governments or canadian health officials
eric sorensen global news toronto well
one of the highly transmissible variants
has already spread through a senior's
home in ontario with deadly consequences
today the ontario government admitted it
will miss its deadline to get the first
dose of vaccine to
all long-term care residents and other
vulnerable people
one part of containing the spread of the
variants is restricting
travel as ross lord explains experts say
canada should have acted
long ago you're always on edge all the
time
these are terrifying times for debbie
grigg following the christmas holidays
her 75 year old mother evelyn contracted
covet 19.
the variant first found in the uk is
tearing through her long-term care home
in berry ontario in less than a month
more than 60 residents
have died my greatest fear is getting
that phone call
saying that my mother has passed away
it's
i think that's why i don't sleep most of
the nights the suspected cause of the
outbreak is travel
health officials say it proves again how
critical it is for people to stay at
home
but researchers say containing the
spread of covet 19 variants will take
more coordination than canada has shown
so far
so there are different levels of
jurisdiction different
policies across provinces there's not
one there's a joined up
whole of government approach to this the
public health agency of canada says
it's up to provincial and other health
officials to warn travelers directly
they might have been exposed to coven 19
on commercial flights
but quebec's department of health and
social services said there is no
individual follow-up with potentially
exposed travelers and that
they are responsible for checking the
government of canada website
to see if a case of covet was
subsequently detected on their flight
and to follow the quarantine act since
the start of the pandemic there have
been more than 8.5 million
border crossings into canada canada
border services says
74 of those crossings or 6.3 million
were by people exempted from quarantine
measures because they were considered
essential
there's renewed pressure on the federal
government to make sure its new travel
rules work
i think this should have been done
months ago this epidemiologist suggests
canada is playing catch up with the
highly contagious new variants
how much can we vaccinate before becomes
dominant can we
harden our long-term care centers can we
protect our health care workers
can we be in a position to prevent a
likely third wave in the late spring
the new variants are not unstoppable
almost two weeks after nova scotia
reported cases from both the uk variant
and the one first detected in south
africa
there's been no new outbreak health
authorities credit the tedious but
effective methods most canadians have
followed for almost a year
and will be asked to continue practicing
for the foreseeable future
ross lord global news students and
parents in ontario found out today
most of the province's shuttered schools
will reopen to
in-person learning on monday elementary
and secondary schools in 13 public
health units in southern ontario will
return to the classroom
february 8. those in the province's
coven 19 hot spots
toronto peel region and york region will
resume
in-person learning february 16th before
and after school child care programs
will also resume
on those same days the newly retired
chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance is being
investigated after global news reported
allegations of
inappropriate sexual behavior vance
stepped down from the military's top job
last month but
remains a member of the forces mercedes
stevenson broke this story and joins us
now with new developments
mercedes sophie an officer in the
canadian armed forces has come forward
to global news
saying she is the woman who general
jonathan vance carried on an intimate
relationship with
during his time at cds as well as while
she was under his command in 2006.
vance has denied the relationship with
sexual during either of those time
periods
global news has agreed to protect the
woman's identity the woman has alleged
that the two exchanged sexually explicit
messages
and have had an intimate relationship on
and off since 2001
since global news began asking questions
the female officer alleges that general
vance
has called her repeatedly she told
global news i know of at least four
phone calls that i answered
that he dictated to me testimony and
what to say and what not to say
repeatedly he told me what i was allowed
to say and what i was not allowed to say
the woman also alleges vance told her to
say they did not have sex because it's
true
but she says she won't do that due to
fears over
abuse of authority of the command
relationship in the military
subordinates in the chain of command are
not allowed to have a relationship with
superiors
if general vance at any material time
during a relationship had any authority
over that other person's rank
progression
evaluation or career
decision making then that's going to
give rise to what's referred to as an
adverse relationship
all right mercedes what's next for vance
well the woman told global news that she
has identified herself to the chain of
command as the woman in our story and
military sources confirm that
under military rules this will likely
trigger an investigation
i fear situations like these erode the
trust you have in leadership said
admiral art mcdonald in a message to
canadian forces
he is the new cds what that
investigation that he is promising looks
like
is unclear it is unprecedented for
someone of such a high rank
to face this kind of an investigation
but dnd is pledging it will be
independent
global news has learned that
high-ranking government officials
were aware of concerns about potentially
inappropriate behavior by the cds
as early as 2018 they say that they
reported those concerns to the privy
council office
all right thanks for that mercedes
stephenson in ottawa
the proud boys are declared terrorists
in canada
coming up the implications for the far
right group and
anyone who wants to join it
[Music]
an american company's facial recognition
technology
clearly violated federal and provincial
privacy laws according to canada's
privacy commissioner
his report found clearview a.i subjected
canadians to illegal
mass surveillance daniel taryan says the
company
collected highly sensitive biometric
information
without the knowledge or consent of
individuals
clearview ai amassed and analyzed
billions of images of faces people
posted to popular social media sites
it sold software or offered trials of it
to multiple police forces in the u.s and
canada
terian calls the company's behavior
completely unacceptable
it is an affront to individuals privacy
rights
and inflicts broad-based harm on all
members of society
who find themselves continually in a
police lineup
clearview ai stopped offering its
services in canada last year
in response to the investigation class
action lawsuits and other government
privacy investigations are underway
around the world clearview ai denies
breaking any laws in canada or anywhere
else
the company says taking and analyzing
photographs that people publicly post on
the internet
is not an invasion of privacy the
canadian government has designated 13
new groups as terrorist entities
including
most notably the proud boys canada is
the first country in the world to add
them to this kind of list
the decision will freeze assets and make
it illegal to contribute to groups
labeled a serious terror threat abigail
beeman takes a look at what it all means
the proud boy central to the deadly riot
at the u.s capitol
the canadian government says the event
contributed to their intelligence and
decision
but they've been watching the group for
much longer they're saying the
authorities know that these
individuals have actually engaged in
really concrete planning or conspiring
to do something violent the proud boys
is one of 13 groups added to canada's
list of terrorist entities and one of
four the government describes as
ideologically motivated violent
extremist groups
the others include three daesh and five
al-qaeda affiliates
no matter the ideological motivation of
violent extremist groups
they are all hateful intolerant and as
we have seen
they can be dangerous we were at great
risk let nobody make any mistake about
this
this is not 10 years ago this is at a
time where anything can happen
these groups were planning um all kinds
of uh
nonsense and this will allow
police to do the work that they have to
do in order to shut them down
simply being a member of one of these
groups isn't illegal but with financial
assets frozen
experts say a listing can mean big
consequences
all financial organizations real estate
groups
any kind of group that would have any
kind of interactions with the proud boys
for example for
for organizing meetings or providing
logistical support
or transfers of money holding a property
all these kinds of things now these
groups will have to disassociate
themselves
the public safety minister stresses this
isn't about politics but last week
mps voted unanimously in favor of the
ndp's motion to add the proud boys to
the list
we need to change our approach with the
outcome of dismantling these groups
there are as many as 300 white
supremacist violence groups that exist
in canada that pose an existential
threat
to canadians we need to be seeing action
on those groups as well
but it was an important step today
abigail beeman global news
ottawa still ahead a destructive fire
hits homes outside of perth australia
an out of control bushfire keeps raging
in western australia
hundreds more people had to make a
last-minute dash to safety
fleeing their homes on the outskirts of
perth the city is back in lockdown after
the first case of covet 19
in months was detected there the fierce
fast-moving fire doubled in size
overnight
it's the biggest the city has seen in
years
11 000 hectares have burned and 71 homes
have been lost
many more are in danger as relentless
winds keep fanning the flames
in russia independent monitors of the
police estimate 10 thousand people have
been taken into custody
since opposition leader alexei navalny
was arrested
and after his prison sentence yesterday
riot police
cracked down again
demonstrations in moscow and saint
petersburg were beaten back
riot police appeared to grab protesters
without obvious provocation
throwing them into police vehicles
journalists have been arrested too
and human rights groups say some people
are unaccounted for
the kremlin calls the protests illegal
and unauthorized and accuses the west
of descending into hysteria over
navalny's imprisonment
he was sentenced to three and a half
years in a penal colony a case navalny
says was
fabricated and politically motivated
well after the military coup in myanmar
also known as burma
police have now charged the country's
elected civilian leader
aung san tsuchi has been charged with
possessing
illegally imported walkie-talkies it
gives military leaders a legal reason to
hold her
until at least the middle of this month
tsuchi has not been heard from since the
military coup
february 1st the general who seized
power has imposed a year-long state of
emergency
one for the books next why vancouver
couples stocked up the library shelves
at a local school
who doesn't need this in their lives a
dose of baby pandas
10 of them wiggling their way through
their first photo shoot at china's
leading panda
reserve their debut is to mark the
coming lunar new year
in nine days the year of the ox begins
the cubs range in age from four to six
months
china prides itself on its efforts to
preserve a species that was endangered
for many years
acts of kindness are another thing we
could all use more of these days
this next story is about a canadian
couple who made some quick cash playing
the stock market
and decided to share the wealth robin
gill has their story
the pulp fiction bookstore in vancouver
is in the business of best sellers
but owner chris breshaw may have a real
page turner
it begins when two benevolent book
lovers came into the store
they had bet five thousand dollars on
amc stock
when they woke up the next day they
doubled their money
he said i started thinking about some
way that that my windfall
could benefit you know some other people
in the community they offered the store
a thousand dollars to buy books for a
school in the neighborhood
kind of felt a little guilty as he said
to me i didn't really work or
do anything for this well parents at the
local school were carrying out a book
drive to update the library
the students come from all kinds of
backgrounds and their parents felt they
just weren't represented in the pages
with libraries especially when they're
working with a small budget is they
have you know they have the books that
they have they replace the books when
they can but you know they really have
this kind of collection that is
is not current this windfall will go a
long way
buying up to 200 new books the donors
want to stay
anonymous instead authoring this
statement
give random people some extra money and
they donate to charities
give billionaires extra money and
they'll just store it with all the other
money that they'll never get around to
spending
it's not money i deserved so i'm just
sharing the luck
it's a really beautiful thing the
parents can't believe their luck
that someone would take this you know
this fortune that they had
and spread it around is you know it is
really amazing and
you know it just really is a testament
to the you know the
kind of community that we have here as
for our storyteller chris braeshaw
he hopes others will subscribe to this
kind of good
anyone can duplicate this experience
it's the kind of story that really does
have a happy ending
robin gill global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm sophie louis tonight's
york canada is this elk in east bolton
quebec
there are beautiful places all over
canada please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching rob and gil will be
here tomorrow